continúan las horas de negociación aquí
en la Cup 27 y es que en la o en las
obras de la noche horario local los
delegados siguen discutiendo los puntos
más difíciles que son precisamente de
adaptación mitigación finanzas y
pérdidas y daños al respecto hay una
gran división entre el llamado g77 más
china que reúne a dos terceras partes de
los países del mundo y en contraposición
la Unión Europea y Estados Unidos pero
detrás del g77 también hay apoyos como
el grupo africano y varios países
latinoamericanos que están diciendo
ellos al respecto María Laura rojas
directora de transforma nos explicó Cuál
es la postura de los latinos la posición
de América Latina en términos de los
andamage o de pérdidas y daños es una
que es compartida con el g77 Y esto es
un tema muy importante porque el grupo
no siempre se une pero en este tema
pérdidas y daño si están unidos están
negociando como bloque y la posición ha
sido muy clara muy consistente incluso
desde años anteriores desde Glasgow y en
esta Cup que se espera que el proceso
adopte la creación de un fondo para
pérdidas y daños al que puedan acceder
los países en desarrollo para atender
mitigar y manejar las pérdidas y daños
que son causadas por los efectos
adversos del cambio climático la Unión
Europea hizo una propuesta para crear un
fondo y financiar las pérdidas y los
daños esto es la primera vez que la
Unión Europea lo hace Cómo respondieron
los latinos esto respondió María Laura
la respuesta en general es que esta es
una movida de negociación que es muy
desafortunada realmente para los países
en desarrollo porque lo que se necesita
es el establecimiento del fondo y estas
condiciones que para empezar no tendría
por qué la Unión Europea estar poniendo
condiciones para que los países en
desarrollo que no han causado El
problema del cambio climático
principalmente puedan acceder a recursos
para atender los efectos adversos
entonces empezando porque no debería
haber condiciones al respecto las son
unos temas que son de muy difícil
resolución en el proceso de negociación
por como lo hemos visto en los últimos
años y eso de facto lo que causa es
mucha dificultad para la decisión de
adopción del fondo